la prima è tornato di testori nuova
challenge erkic circo in tantissimi ci
avete richiesto la px allensbach ho
pensato facciamo la torta challenge
abbiamo fatto come sorte base di torte
quindi non sono pronte e ci sono tre
strati di torta allora come funziona
questa sale su dovremmo riempire di
strati della torta e decorarla con gli
ingredienti secchi stato credi e che
saranno scelti dalla ruota però alcuni
ingredienti ingredienti chi fossi ma per
uccisi degli ingredienti buonissimi
oppure potrebbe riuscirci degli critichi
schifosi voi alla fine del video dovrete
votare chi ha vinto in base a chi ha la
torta più bella e più buona secondo voi
metterò il sondaggio alla fine del video
quindi mi raccomando chelante video fino
alla fine poi voterebbe se ho vinto io o
se ha vinto vitale o e una volta che
abbiamo finito di te curarla supremo
ovviamente assaggiarla stiamo anche
decidere se tentare la torta dell'altra
persona
tutto questo video se volete vedere
altre sale del genere 10.000 lex andremo
a farne un'altra riguardante appunto una
talent sul cibo tipo questa consigliate
su pure voi nei commenti quale volete
che facciamo oltre alla pizza spalle di
quello lo faremo sicuramente
allora mettetevi comodi fatati e bob
corn entriamo subito ok siamo pronti
iniziamo dal primo strato quindi andiamo
un parola ha preferito strada non può
sperare di vedere come sia questa torta
ok
iniziamo bene che bel sito paga quindi
adattare un bel po di pane la frutta
spruzzare su tutta la torta in realtà fu
enorme
[Musica]
ora andrò around no siccome non ci sono
tutti politi e coloranti per colorante
bisogna sceglierlo pcb quindi chiudi gli
occhi
[Musica]
durante verde quindi perché il
presidente vediamo un po come lo mette
allora colorante verde entrano se faccio
un cerchio portare un nino e perché lo
volevo spalmare questo triste per ora la
mia ha un aspetto miliare guardati belle
decorazioni con la panna detto che a me
vado il miele bene finora fango bene
speriamo anche con sentiamo un po di
miele
non possiamo esserne troppo sono di
vista troppo non è altri che ha già un
bellissimo aspetto la mia torta invio
già completato il mio primo strato
sembra già un buon allora chiudiamo il
dimostrato
[Musica]
ieri finora sembra molto buona
speriamo che continui così ok tutto come
adesso ha interesse come ingrediente del
100 modello e colorante la faccina
triste adesso che mettiamo la nutella
diventerà sicuramente più non esagera e
diventerà sicuramente più felice questa
pagina ma adesso siamo al di là del
colore diventa marrone merda non si vede
molto traversa mentre dolorante e ora
chiude gli occhi verde allora puoi
scegliere questo no metti insieme alla
costiera ma mai nato tre anni fa trovare
una perdita augustus la mamma mia
allora sono quattro adesso
[Musica]
ci credo no non l'aiuta giorgio bene
così giovani giorno a tutti e quattro
stato logico tenermelo vediamo disegni
un gatto vediamo tesse palazzo fosse più
facile stare queste penne credo i baffi
almeno questa merda e più carino destra
fissi e un gatto re ecco fattori piazza
il mio gatto nella torta e donne bianche
ma no dai scherzo
attenzione però c'è anche uno scambio
per dare a cambiarla di mangiare tutto
il viso le mete si rifiuta proprio di
una parte nella cattura di gesù e
propone una torta che buoni buonissimi e
pronto a mangiarli che tocca a me baby
pure ponte tutti i pregi
adesso perde comunque cetriolini fa una
mia dei centralini
questo fatto è ritagliato sicuro chissà
magari poi scopriamo che buoni
mais delle centrali ha un aspetto
terrificante buonissima ottimo dolce
sapore
[Musica]
ha fatto bene di prima si progetta
parente che ha lo stesso prova detta
bubi treze e la lezione dai amo la vita
peccato allora colorante chiudi gli
occhi uno giallo benissimo come vittima
sembra tipo maionese o montar sala che
tanto perché caramello peccato per il
centro libero sarebbe stata buoni come
tranne contro l'inter per terra buona
puoi vedere la sua e mezzo di buyer che
spider che è bellissima invece no è
capitato il piccolo diventerà testarda
con cetrioli a buy da parte di mosca
dopo a tor palanza dopo vediamo con te
lo fa per te
prima mi ha decisamente meglio non farà
da dessert nello stesso piatto due mesi
20 nov
ma com'è possibile che scavi danze cose
mi sono sentita nella mia città
differenti
[Applauso]
[Musica]
troppo non è chiuso che ci capitano
stesse cose ma lo ha detto la motta cosa
posso mettere per migliorare questa
porta adesso questi segni e decorazione
allora abbiamo queste palline bianche e
rosa erano io nei test altri non mi
piaccio incassi da questo il ci stanno
proprio bene nel mais e petrioli siccome
questo è l'ultimo e poi chiudono tratto
vediamo smettiamo di coprire mai dai
bravi a una torta la tua proprio lista
ma un po bella che mai
[Musica]
brano un bacio chiuderla guardate qua c
3 1 che cerca di scappare vitale e poi
dovrà chiuderla anche lupi sino al
caramello attenzione per ogni occhio
talk show vediamo un po pauline
caramello caramello miele è veramente in
vita potevo dire che la composizione
molto carina e abbiamo chiuso le nostre
torte ma non è finita qua perché ma non
lo decorate anche sopra ci sono ancora
state di ingredienti che non abbiamo
ancora viva parla così la posso anche
ricoprire tutta perché essendo l'ultimo
strato fa anche affrontare mi metto
guarda bene pare parto dai lati
io dovevo vincere
allora partiamo da facciamo così meglio
consumare questa lascia per un po di
gloria
basta spettacolo è finito sono molto
brava della decorazione ma forse ci sta
pure setta la vedono messo troppo ad
hayden e regala un po offerto grazie se
nostra bordata è vero nel male che aiuta
un po le fonti la mustang a rubare più
delle già abbastanza città e non è male
ma neanche pellettiera tua guarda tutela
che fortuna che non mettermi troppa
[Musica]
fichissimi tutti al mente non mi era mai
capitato
e io sento le decorazioni rosa perché
sono bellissime vediamo un po come si fa
si sta diventato retata patata mettiamo
in parte alla fine si dovranno mangiare
anche io scelgo anch'io passi mariani ad
essere sotto lo zero il copione news o
no non ci posso credere che alla fine se
scambio ma non ci posso credere a tutto
quel a parma che sta apportando sta
portando dappertutto mio torto
[Musica]
[Applauso]
dobbiamo finire con una torta in faccia
tribolata tanti e per dare magari se
facciamo lo scambio è la bellissima idea
rapitori sono bellissimi finalmente c'è
un po di colore e anatemi mai terminata
per sempre
[Musica]
beh io almeno solo naturale certo ma
andando così bene
guardate con troppo
papà
ma ci stanno male dal momento che questi
sono i pop corn dolci e salate per amia
più carina top ma guarda tu minatori era
bellissimo la mia torta fatata che sta
dicendo anche colori stupendi mangiarlo
sta bene con rosa il violetto allora i
ragazzi ora è arrivato il momento di
farlo e poi dovrete votare perfetto e
per bus
questo vuol dire monocoli anche se ve lo
potrete immaginare i normali che dia
molta che era una bella fetta che rumori
croccanti sicuramente i cetrioli
ora vediamo anche come dentro un
invitante tanto
[Musica]
se non avete avuto se non avesse avuto i
cetrioli e il mais sarebbe stata
buonissima
guardate dentro mi ami ami
ok ora è arrivato il momento di mangiare
dedizione come è molto strano perché si
sente precedente tutti in evidente il
sapore buono della nutella o dell'attore
della panna e poi il retrogusto di
meister c38 brava tutta la devi mangiare
sì sì che buona io ero
[Musica]
eccoci qua dei bravi io questa parte ci
tre ore i tifosi vogliono gara si sente
qui la contentezza di chi trio voli
siamo pronti a vederla non si spendono
interiori dove sono le i premi del
futuro guarda bene qui guardandola non
l'ha trovato se n'è poco io ho preso un
pezzo enorme
adesso fammi modo assaggiarlo è il mais
lei beccato in mai veramente nella torta
[Musica]
a me rimasto ancora troppo in
bookmarking viviamo come la torta bella
peccato perché sto poi era carina più
bello l'amica quello che ho fatto io
basta ma guarda non proprio pc senza
questo io ho fatto quasi tutta io
veramente come fight è proprio un
mangione di mangini vostra burke
emittenti è più buona
sì ma le cose il cetriolo per quello di
cuore contrapposto bene cetraro non
dello tanto buono che manderebbe queste
mi ricordo le 180 mentre ogni maestro
suono un po
allora ragazzi voltatevi mezz'ora qua il
sondaggio ti ho vinto io o se ha vinto
vitale e guardate un po anche se ne
attacco e l'hanno fatta un pò che io e
quello è stato un po più montante che ha
vinto tevinter ioni tale eva vista per
quali aree attrezzate che facciamo
assieme sia con la ruota che senza ruota
scrivete su tutti i notisti inserimenti
di commenti e chi dovrà prendere anche
una data in faccia
[Applauso]
noi cercheremo di salvare più possibile
questa torta per evitare di sprecare il
cibo quindi toglieremo petrolini e mais
salveremo quello che c'è di buono perché
per il mais è molto buona adattabilità
10 pure dei commenti da est a un tool
del momento che vi ha fatto più ridere
che volevo comprare vedermi in ridono
tacco di carattere figure darceli ora vi
lasciamo cappato quadratini su cui
potete cliccare per vedere le nostre
altre challenge assieme i vostri video
divertenti cliccate su quella che
preferite e buona visione
ciao ciao